Sheila katkar author of black edge who
is Stephen Cohen Stephen Cohen was and
continues to be a legendary figure in
the financial world he built up an
enormous personal fortune almost
entirely on the basis of his incredible
skill for trading so he he had a really
strong instinct for the stock market he
would sit down behind his screens and
just sort of look at the way stocks were
trading every day and was believed to
have this very intuitive incredible
sense of how to sort of ride the waves
in the market and make money and he has
this very compelling almost rags to
riches story he grew up very
middle-class in Great Neck Long Island
which was an affluent town his family
had relatively speaking less money than
a lot of others around him so I think
from an early age you know he felt a
sort of hunger to become rich you know
he was very good at playing poker he
started playing poker in high school he
went to Wharton famous business school
and then he launched his hedge fund sa C
capital in 1992 and very quickly built
up a multi-billion dollar fortune and he
has the lifestyle to match a 36 thousand
square foot mansion in Greenwich
Connecticut helicopter rides 100
million-dollar works of art his own ice
rink and Zamboni so he became an object
of extreme envy on Wall Street very
quickly s a C capital does it stand for
the obvious yes his initials Steven a
Cohen he he embodied the firm in every
way late in your book there's a moment
where you come in contact with him and
he you say in your book that he wouldn't
talk to you for this book tell us about
that moment well I had spent several
years reporting this book and I went
about doing that the way any
investigative reporter does you know
oyster I had a lot of court documents I
did a lot of interviews with people and
I had tried multiple times to you know
convince him to sit with me and of
course I would have loved to talk with
him and by the time the story reached
its conclusion and the
you refer to in the book he had largely
won the legal case it I thought you know
he may have a compelling reason to
actually talk now he kind of he beat the
system you know he's he's trying to
remake his reputation so I heard he was
going to be attending a very sort of
rarefied special art auction at
Christie's auction house in Manhattan
and you know I'd met with Steve Cohen
staff and his people several times I'd
written him letters but you know and
they'd always said well maybe he'll meet
with you but they never really said no
so I went there and I just sort of
ambushed him you know I I knew he was
gonna come he was selling a painting
that night and I stood in the door and I
saw him come in and it was it was the
first time I actually really spoken to
him directly and it was you know was a
powerful moment for me because I felt
like I knew him so well at this point I
had spoken to dozens of people had
worked with them as family members and
you know we did a brief exchange and he
basically as soon as he figured out who
I was he sort of said oh you know I
don't think I can really talk to and he
sort of ran away and he looked very
relaxed he arrived just before the
auction was set to begin which I thought
was just interesting because he's so
important in the art world he's
literally one of the biggest and most
important modern art collectors in the
world
he knew that Christie's would never
start without him I mean he was a VIP in
that world so you know and I sort of
said to him you know what are you doing
tonight are you buying or selling and I
knew it had been reported he was selling
a painting out of his collection and he
said oh no I'm selling I'm selling and
then he went into the auction and just a
few minutes later he paid I think it was
a hundred and forty million dollars for
Giacometti sculpture let me stop you
let's look at a little piece of video
that shows people what he paid a hundred
and forty I think you say I'm in 41
million let's just watch this how could
that be worth a hundred and forty 1
million dollars well it is worth
whatever someone is willing to pay for
it that's how the market works and it is
interesting because he I think Cohen is
reported to have purchase at least two
of those sculptures for 140 million
dollar range he'd bought one prior to
this one that was pointing man I think
he'd bought he purchased another one
called chariot as well
I think part of the reason the prices
have become so elevated for these
particular works of art is because this
very very small group of hedge fund
billionaires in particular have become
competitive about art collecting and you
know I think it happened to a lot of
them that they they achieved a lot of
financial success fairly early and they
sort of realized that they were still
not seen as these sort of sophisticated
cultured people they were just thought
of as Wall Street guys and many of them
became interested in the art world you
know it was a way to just enter this
whole other universe of sort of high
culture and you would have your photo up
here in the society pages you could get
your name onto a wall in a museum
so many of Cohen's contemporaries became
really interested in art and they they
end up in the sort of arms race bidding
a certain artists into these
stratospheric prices and there is you
know a lot of people believe there's a
big bubble in art market how much is he
worth today I believe it's at least 10
billion dollars he you know by the time
all of this legal drama ended he was
forced to sort of shut down his hedge
fund s AC capital but he was still
allowed to manage his own money through
his private family office so he's he's
got a pool of his own money it's upwards
of ten billion dollars and he still
trades it every day in the market so his
lifestyle is largely unchanged from what
it was before how many people when he
had s AC capital went to prison or they
were convicted or they pled and are
gonna be sentenced
how many around him well at least eight
were either convicted or pled guilty
however the two you know these were
either former or current sec employees a
handful of others were connected to
insider trading more indirectly however
the two kind of central characters at
the heart of the story they're they're
very central characters in my book are
these two former portfolio managers for
Cohen's fund
Mathew martoma is one of them and
Michael Steinberg is the other one and
Mar Thoma is currently serving a fairly
lengthy prison sentence although whose
case is on appeal and mr. Steinberg was
convicted but then his conviction was
later overturned after an appeals court
made a ruling that made it much harder
to convict someone for insider trading
and he is now doing other things with
his life has Stephen Cohen ever been
convicted of anything or charged with
anything no absolutely not well I should
clarify the SEC did charge him with
failing to supervise his employees that
was sort of the final thing that
happened but it was a fairly light
charge that was settled for a financial
penalty and some modifications to his
business but he was never charged with
any crime himself and there was sort of
a dramatic moment in the story which I
recount in the book where you know the
government the Department of Justice FBI
and the SEC lawyers had spent years
trying to build up a case against Cohen
and they had been you know trying to
flip people and get co-operators who
could lead them inside s AC they had
wiretap some people they had been
tracking him for years and finally in
2013 there's sort of this dramatic
moment where they have to decide okay
what are we going to do in the entire
world was watching this was a very
high-profile case there was tremendous
news media coverage the financial
industry was sort of riveted wanted to
know whether this huge star of their
world was possibly going to go to jail
and I described this scene in the book
where mr. Cohen's lawyers came in to
meet with the prosecutors and make a
presentation and tried to persuade them
not to charge their client and this is
something that apparently happens you
know many defendants are given the
opportunity to come in and sort of
present their defense
so handful of Steve Cohen's very
high-priced defense lawyers came in
there and they were around 17 government
attorneys President these were SCC
lawyers criminal prosecutors FBI agents
all these people who had been involved
in different aspects of the case
and mr. Cohen's lawyers either made a
four-hour presentation they gave out
these binders to everyone in the room
and they basically made the argument
that you know there was a very critical
email that people were wondering whether
Cohen had read it and contained what
they believed was inside information and
his lawyers essentially said you have no
proof he read the email you have no
witness to put on the stand he knew the
government was very nervous about losing
a big case so they really targeted that
weakness and they said you have no one
to put on the stand and say they saw him
do it or they talked about it with him
you know there's no evidence he read
this email even if he did read the email
it might not be illegal and they just
sort of hammered that point home over
and over again and the government
attorneys left that meeting and they
still felt fairly sure of what they felt
which was like oh it really looked
pretty bad it looked like Cohen might be
guilty of something however they had to
go and have a really hard conversation
about the evidence they had and what
they could do with it and they ended up
deciding that they did not have enough
evidence to bring to a jury and be sure
that they could win so they ended up in
dai ting Cohen's company instead of
Cohen himself and that company paid how
much in total in total 1.8 billion
dollars that was one chunk of that was
an SEC fine and 1.2 billion
approximately was sort of a criminal
settlement once in a while I see that
you weren't a traitor where did that all
start and we needed to find things like
what is insider trading sure so I one of
the reasons I became interested in this
story and it really connected with me is
because I started my career working at
two very small hedge funds I was
actually an analyst which is a little
different from a trader so the analyst
is though is there the egghead who does
the research traders are the ones who
sit there and decide when to buy or sell
and you know often people making
decisions about trades will talk to the
analysts and they'll say well was this a
good company she would put our money in
this company or should we be selling
this you know what's happening what's
going to happen in the future what are
the product order
like and you know my job was to trying
to analyze our investments and then help
guide the portfolio manager and making
these decisions and then a trader would
execute them so you know it's important
to understand this word edge to kind of
understand the concept of inside
information so inside Steve Cohen former
hedge fund si si
there was a portfolio manager who had
this system for rating information and
he tried to teach it to the young guys
working for him so that they could stay
out of trouble because it's a constant
concern that you're going to end up with
some information that you shouldn't have
and you know hedge funds are very driven
by information the better the
information is that you have the the
more likely you are to make money if you
have bad information you're going to
lose money so everybody's out there in
the market every day trying to get the
best sharpest most useful information
let me ask you first again about a hedge
fund can I invest in a hedge fund it
that depends on what your investable
assets are meaning yes small no in
general hedge funds are intended to
cater to wealthy investors who can
afford in theory to lose the money they
put in what's the difference between
buying a stock from a company or through
a broker and investing in a hedge fund
well so hedge funds were conceived as
this boutique kind of rarefied product
that were catering that was catering
towards wealthy investors and the idea
was that a hedge fund was going to take
a lot more risk in the market
potentially than a regular mutual fund
for example where you know at fidelity
or State Street so you know regulators
looked at this and they said well you
know if you're gonna be taking all this
risk if you're gonna be borrowing money
and trading it or if you're going to be
shorting stocks which is basically
betting that a stock will go down rather
than up and it's a very risky activity
and not everyone does it
the SEC kind of said you can only do
that if you're only taking money from
people who could afford to lose the
money we don't want you taking money
from
middle-class you know dentists or
teachers or whoever who will be
devastated if they lose this money well
this was a little why is the government
telling you're protecting me
well you that's the purpose of
securities regulators is to make sure
the market is fair and transparent and
that people aren't getting fleeced by
these fancy hedge fund guys how many
hedge funds are there thousands that all
make money I would I would argue that
probably most of them do not make money
but a handful of them make a tremendous
amount of money and they have made the
founders of the hedge funds extremely
wealthy and partly this is because they
charge very hefty fees much higher fees
than you would pay to Vanguard or you
know any of your mutual fund companies I
mean they charge typically two to three
percent of the assets that they're
managing so in other words if I gave
them a million dollars they would take
two percent off the top just to kind of
cover their overhead then at the end of
the year they figure out what profit
they made let's say they make a hundred
percent profit in other words their
whole hedge fund starts out being worth
ten billion at the end of the year it's
worth twenty billion so they're gonna
take that look at that profit that one
hundred percent profit and depending on
the fund they're going to take twenty
percent sometimes even fifty percent of
that profit and keep it for themselves
and that is known as an incentive fee
that is supposed to be motivation for
the hedge fund manager to not do
anything really foolish and to work
really hard to make money for how much
did mr. Cohen take from that he he had
some of the highest fees in the business
fifty percent and I will say that even
with those high fees his returns were
spectacular he especially during his
earlier period he was often returning 30
40 70 percent and investors were
fighting to get into his fund all the
time because he was just churning out
profits and when did you work in that
anti hedge fund I was working at a hedge
fund from around let me think here 98 to
2002 and how big was that big was the
office tiny
and I will say right now this five six
yeah oh yeah last fewer than ten
employees both of them and this is how
this is how Steve Cohen's hedge fund
started and this is how the whole hedge
fund industry began during that period I
mean a lot of hedge funds started by
just one or two people who just did not
want to go work at Goldman Sachs they
didn't want they didn't want to have to
deal with the big corporate culture
there they didn't want to wear suits you
know they were smart they just want to
make money they were scrappy and
ambitious so a lot of these hedge funds
were little shops opened up by two or
three people and often you know
especially you know if the people were
doing well they would grow very quickly
and you know you say for instance you're
at this small hedge fund and I have a
lot of money and I call you up and who
do I talk to when I call up well it
depends if you're a small small I'm a
small hedge fund you might call up and
speak to the fund manager if you're a
slick sophisticated multi-billion dollar
hedge fund you will talk to a department
that is there to cater to investors
let's say I call the hedge fund say I'd
like to invest do I just write you a
check
it's a little more complicated than that
you have to kind of prove that you have
enough net worth to qualify to be an
investor it's also possible that the
particular hedge fund if it's a very hot
in-demand hedge fund might not just take
money from anybody I mean this this
often happens with the really hot
high-performing ones they can kind of
pick which investors they want and what
kind of people work in a hedge fund
office what kind of people do you mean
like the staff position we walk in there
what good where these folks come from
well male/female minorities in the
business sure I mean I will say that
hedge funds became very quickly one of
the most effective and efficient
vehicles to kind of become extremely
wealthy they became known as places to
go if you wanted to get really really
rich and you can make more money to
hedge fund than you could even at a big
bank like the Goldman Sachs or JP Morgan
so eventually over time hedge funds
started attracting the best
students out of Ivy League colleges math
graduates from MIT young ambitious
hungry kids with PhDs and science and
computer programming often these people
are flocking to headquarters where did
you come from - to a hedge fund well I
came from a very different background I
thought what is it
where'd you grow up Toronto parents were
from my father's from India my mother's
from the Midwest is that the Cole hat
card name yes that is a South Asian name
one of the things that's interesting we
haven't been your book is there a lot of
Indian Americans that are you're writing
about did that cross your mind as you're
writing but I mean it was obvious it was
remarkable I mean there are a lot of
South Asians sort of in all corners and
in the government side and the hedge
fund world and I asked people why that
with anyone thought about that and you
know the one explanation I got was that
many of these sort of insider trading
rings that the government was pursuing
are spring up out of personal
relationships and personal networks and
often people end up involved in that
kind of behavior with their friends and
their the people they went to college
with so you would end up with these
circles of people where yes you'd have
certain groups over-represented and it
was interesting to me you went to school
where I graduated from NYU New York
University and what I have a degree in
film in film yeah yep and what did you
do after you work for the hedge fund
well I spent about five years working
for these two hedge funds it wasn't at
all what I'd intended to do is you can
discern from the fact that I have a film
degree and I kind of fell into it by
accident and the whole time I was there
it was sorta I mean I learned a
tremendous amount and I actually love
that but I felt a bit like an
anthropologist in this world that was
really foreign to me and every year I
would kind of say to myself okay you
know I'm I'm gonna do this for what
year and then I'm gonna get out and I'm
gonna go become a writer or a journalist
I'm gonna do something else and then
every year I get a bonus and I would
think uh well you know maybe I should
stay a little longer and you know I
think that's what I think that's what
draws a lot of people into that world
the the money draws people in did you
make a lot of money when you were there
not relative to what a lot of money
would be now but for me at the time it
was a lot and your job now is what I'm a
staff writer at The New Yorker this is a
very detailed book about a lot of names
and all we're not gonna be able to get
into but I want to jump right into
something this is from 2011
thanks to PBS Frontline you were on this
program and it's a I think it ran in
2014 and it's available on the website
if people want to watch it's an hour but
here's Stephen Cohen in a deposition
which I want you to explain what did you
see there where is that from that
deposition was a it was a video of a
deposition he gave in a case that was
really a private commercial litigation
involving a company called Fairfax which
isn't Canadian insurance company that
had accused a bunch of hedge funds of
manipulating its stock did you watch all
of that deposition I've watched some of
it I if I've watched all of it it's
available on the PBS Frontline website
by the way if people want to watch yes
yeah no it's interesting it's
interesting I remember when I remember
when those were leaked it was quite
dramatic can we're gonna jump around
people that want to know more it's in
the book they can read it but I want to
go to 2008 Chicago Illinois dr. Sid
Gillman oh yes set it up please who is
dr. Sid Gillman
well dr. Gillman was a very accomplished
Alzheimer's researcher University
mission at the University of Michigan he
he was a head of the medical department
there he you know he authored medical
papers he mentored students he helped
with drug trials he was a lion of the
scientific community very highly
regarded he was in his 70s I think at
the time many of the events in the book
took place and you know at one point one
of Steve Cohen's portfolio managers
Mathew martoma you know decided that he
wanted to research a drug trial he
wanted to invest in the development of
this drug there were two drug companies
creating trying to invent a you know
come up with a cure for Alzheimer's Elan
and Wyeth
yeah those have both been purchased
since then yes I don't remember exactly
what's happened to them but yes they
both had I think they both been taken
over
Pfizer took over Wyeth yeah I can't
remember the name of the company took
over the other one but so we're in
Chicago so developing a drug is
extremely expensive and going through
the FDA drug approval process is
expensive so often companies will team
up to do this and that's what these two
did now Mathew martoma when he arrived
at Steve Cohen's fund he was very
ambitious he wanted to make a lot of
money he was looking for a winning
trading idea and he was an expert in
technology stocks and biotechnology
stocks and drug companies so he he had
been tracking the development of this
Alzheimer's drug and there was
tremendous commercial potential for this
Alzheimer's drug basically for any
company that found a cure for
Alzheimer's there were billions of
dollars to be made this is a disease
with no cure and it's devastating to
millions of people so Mar Thoma started
looking around for people who could help
him learn more about this drug trial and
he ended up becoming connected to dr.
Gillman and over a number of months
cultivated a relationship with dr.
Gillman that culminated in him getting
allegedly inside information from dr.
Gillman about this drug trial and
there's a very dramatic moment that I
recount in the book where dr. Gillman
appears at a
medical conference in Chicago I think
it's in July of 2008 and it's this big
unveiling of the final trial results of
this Alzheimer's drug trial and this
auditorium at a hotel in downtown
Chicago is packed and there are
scientific researchers there there
University presidents there there drug
company representatives there and there
are a lot of traders and analysts from
Wall Street because all of Wall Street
has been sort of gambling one way or
another on the outcome of his drug trial
so dr. Gilman stands up there and sort
of clears his throat and he announces
the drug trial results and he shows this
whole PowerPoint and he was trying to be
optimistic because I think he was so
hopeful and wanted so badly for these
this drug to work but ultimately the
people in the audience understood that
the trial had shown that the drug was
not working it was not it was not you
know it was not it was not becoming more
effective if you took a higher dose you
know there all sorts of problems with it
so immediately everyone on Wall Street
starts trying to sell sell sell sell
these sort of code red alerts go out
everyone's dumping their shares well it
turned out Mar Thoma allegedly had
gotten this information the week before
an sa C capital had already sold off its
whole position and in fact shorted the
two stocks and you know it really
Illustrated the difference there I mean
all of these people who did not have the
benefit of that information earlier
ended up losing money because the stocks
plunged did you ever enter view dr.
Gillman no did you ever interview Matt
Mar Thoma no I did what's his real name
Mathew martoma a Jai Mathew Mariam dhami
Thomas I believe was his given name and
he did change his name at one point why
you would have to ask him but he's a
story in himself he is quite a character
where is he right now he is in prison in
Florida and his case is on appeal is he
from India originally his family is he's
been
in dissent there was a time when this
man fainted
yes in your store there were several
fainting men in my book yeah I mean just
dropped yeah well
the FBI I mean you know one one day the
FBI decided they were gonna kind of
pursue Mar Thoma and one of the main
characters in the story BJ Kang who is
this very ambitious kind of tough guy
FBI agent korean-american yes he went
down to Florida to approach Mar Thoma at
his home in Boca Raton where he had a
very sort of beautiful expensive house
he was living there with his family and
their hope was that Mar Thoma would flip
and become a cooperator to them and they
had all this that you know they had a
masked a lot of evidence they believed
of this conspiracy involving dr. Gillman
this drug trial and but should I say -
in order to get Steve Cohen that why
they wanted to necessarily wanted him to
flip I think that was their ultimate
hope they would probably never admit
that officially but it seemed quite
clear from the way they were behaving
now Mar Thoma himself was a worthwhile
target on his own
it was a huge insider trading case just
involving Mar Thoma himself but yes I
think they had a lot of questions about
what Mar Thoma had shared with Steve
Cohen so BJ Kang went down there and
confronted Mar Thoma on his front lawn
and he said I want to talk to him it
insider-trading what happened in July of
2008 and Mar Thoma fainted and BJ Kang
you know sort of shook his head and he
had been through many of these
approaches before he had been working on
this case for years
BJ Kang is in the first sentence of your
prologue at the beginning of the book
he's a very key figure in this whole
thing I mean he was one of the central
FBI agents who investigated these cases
and he had yep he did some of the big
arrests he arrested Raj Rajaratnam
who is he he was another big hedge fund
manager who was arrested and charged
before the Mar Thoma case he's
originally from Sri Lanka yes where is
he today he's in prison
I believe in upstate New York I'd have
to double-check
but what's hard for the outsider to
understand is you taught you talk about
three groups of people from the
government that make a difference the
SEC Securities and Exchange Commission
the FBI and the US Attorney's and you
talk a lot in the book about how they
there's jealousy between the two
different departments and all that let
me just show Preet Bharara who is who is
he the US attorney for the Southern
District of New York so the top
prosecutor in Manhattan for the federal
government very important law
enforcement figure what's the name
Barrera India from India very
interesting let's go to Preet Bharara in
November the force in 2013 this past
July we filed a criminal indictment
against for SA C capital related
companies for engaging in insider
trading that was substantial pervasive
and on a scale without precedent in the
history of hedge funds three months
later we are here to announce a
resolution that is matching in its
magnitude all of the charged s AC
companies have agreed to plead guilty
all have agreed to wind down and close
their outside investment businesses and
all have agreed collectively to pay
total fines and penalties in the record
amount of 1.8 billion dollars who is
this man and how does he get to where he
is
he he is the son of immigrants from
India he grew up in New Jersey his
father was a medical doctor and it's
interesting because both he and his
brother Vinny were these incredibly
accomplished students apparently their
parents were extremely demanding sort of
stereotypical Tiger parents you know
wanted them to have straight A's
sacrificed a lot so they could go to
good schools and my understanding is
that Preet wanted to be a prosecutor
from early on in his career you know he
he had he had a very strong sense of
right and wrong he he did a lot of
debate and things like that in high
school
so he enjoyed standing up and arguing
and developing ideas and performing and
he ended up going to you have to double
check he ended up going to either
Columbia or Harvard which was a Columbia
Law School yeah I think Columbia Harvard
undergrad and Columbia Law School
there's a lot of Ivy League graduates in
my book so sometimes I confuse them but
and then he ended up working for Chuck
Schumer the senator from New York as his
sort of one of his chief legal counsel
and Schumer is the one who recommended
him for the job he has now which is this
US Attorney for the Southern District
job and it's one of the most
high-profile jobs you know in in law
enforcement you know New York City has
many of the most high-profile cases it
has terrorism cases narcotics cases
complicated financial crime cases and
Preet was told recently that President
Trump wants him to stay on in the role
which surprised some people since he was
an Obama appointee but again looking at
how this all works you talked about
insider trading and I kind of learned
from you that is not that clear
sometimes what insider trading is well
yeah so I could I mean I there's an easy
way to explain it which is through this
you know by explaining the title of the
book black edge so so there were some
employees at Steve Cohen's firm they had
this method of describing different
types of information there was white
edge which was considered to be
information that was publicly available
that anyone could get like companies
public SEC filings and companies when
they report their earnings they have to
make filings with the Securities and
Exchange Commission anyone can look at
those on the wet on the Internet
so that's white edge everyone kind of
has access to it it's not actually very
valuable for a trader because everyone
has it presumably there's no money to be
made from trading based on its contents
then there's gray edge which is
information that's sort of it's it's
ambiguous for example an analyst might
call an employee of a company and say
you know you announced this merger
how is it going when's the merger going
to close you've announced you know
you've announced this big investment
that's happening when is that gonna
happen would that have been you by the
way when you were yes working I did some
of this exactly and the person may or
may not be authorized to tell you that
information so it depends if you have a
relationship with that person if you're
a very important investor they might say
to you well we're feeling good about it
and so then you go back to your desk and
you think okay hmm was that material
nonpublic information that I am not
supposed to trade on or was that just
you know no big deal and hedge funds are
supposed to have compliance officers and
counsel to help advise you if you end up
in the situation and a lot of the time
the information that these analysts are
getting is in this gray zone so is one
way to describe it it's like they don't
have the kind of rules that you do if
you went to a Vanguard fund or something
like that I mean they just it's they're
not as regulated as some of the other
funds are they are more lightly
regulated that's absolutely true and
they don't have to disclose as much
benefit to rich people some people
believe that now a hedge fund manager
would say a lot of hedge funds do take
money from pension fund managers so they
would say that some of their investors
through these pension funds which will
kind of put chunks of money with
different hedge funds sometimes so they
would say well we're also managing money
for for teachers in California you know
as a group so it's not only rich people
who benefit from us but for the most
part they do cater to rich people that's
correct
we go back to the beginning we talked
about Steve Cohen sitting there and and
making 10 billion or whatever it is he's
not been charged with anything he needs
to have the edge as you say wants to
know information that other people don't
know so I would say that anyone working
at any hedge fund who involved in short
term trading meaning every day they're
coming and trading in and out of stocks
all of those people want edge that is a
common term in the industry they want
edge and you know there's this white
edge it's kind of useless for their
purposes there's the gray zone and then
there's black edge which is clearly
inside information
I want to go back to Matt Mar Thoma oh
you talked about because the Sidney
Gilman story dr. Sidney Gilman makes the
presentation in Chicago but prior to
that you tell the story about Matt
markoma flying to Ann Arbor right ahead
of that speech yep to try to gather new
information about the Alzheimer's drug
but at the same time he is phony about
it he tells dr. young he's coming for
another reason tell that's directly well
so over over a number of months Mar
Thoma has built up this rapport with dr.
Gilman they talked on the phone for
hours they meet for dinner you know they
get together and got the Gilman overtime
he's a bit lonely he starts to see Mar
Thoma almost like a surrogate son you
know he feels very connected to him so
gradually and he knows he's not supposed
to be sharing confidential information
about the Alzheimer's drug but over time
he starts to share it because Mar Thoma
is just pushing and pushing it really
wants this information so at some point
it crosses the line and Gilman starts
sharing information he's not supposed to
be sharing and meanwhile Mar Thoma is
back at sa C capital working for Steve
Cohen he's advocating very hard for them
to invest very heavily in Elan and Wyeth
these two drug stocks he's saying this
this Alzheimer's drug trial is going
really well if I'm Steve Cohen and Matt
Mar Thoma is working for me and he comes
in to him and says we got to short this
because this isn't going to work does he
is the issue at that moment does he tell
him that he has gotten this from dr.
Gillman well there's some mystery at the
center of it because ultimately what
happened is after pushing and advocating
for months to be to aggressively
invest in these two companies on the
basis of this trial
you know Mar Thoma and there were other
people at us they see who were against
the idea because they didn't think the
drug trial was going to work out and
there was this constant debate and
arguing and no one could understand why
is Marton was so confident this is
really weird and at one point one of
Martinez colleagues says he's seen he's
acting like he has black edge what's
going on and they couldn't get an answer
so there was all this
fighting and the sort of mystery
swirling around it so it seems a little
fishy right so then the government
alleges and they had you know but they
presented it Martin was trial you know
airplane tickets phone records they had
all sorts of documentary evidence that
you know the week before the trial was
publicly announced in Chicago that Mar
Thoma flew to the University of Michigan
to visit dr. Gillman went into dr.
Gilman's office looked at the
presentation that dr. Gillman was
working on that had all of the final
drug trial results in it confidential
presentation Gilman had received this
under lock and key from elan so Mar
Thoma is alleged have looked at this he
gets he gets back in his taxi goes back
to the airport flies back home and then
on Sunday morning the following day
there's a phone call with Steve Cohen
and at Martinez trial the government
presented some of this evidence you know
he sends an email to Steve Cohen in the
morning Sunday morning not a typical
time for a work call like this and he
says I need to speak with you it's
important they talked on the phone no
one knows what they said and then
immediately afterwards mr. Cohen starts
instructing his traders to sell off
their shares and they spend the next
week sort of liquidating their whole
position almost a billion dollars really
quietly and it's important to note that
there are many reasons why you do that
quietly I mean if someone if people hear
that Steve Cohen is dumping shares of
Elan and why if you know it can almost
trigger like a response let me show you
some video this is here before the last
that we showed you Preet Bharara who is
the US Attorney Southern District of New
York
pointed by which President Obama
President Obama would you say by the way
that those positions often lead to
running for attorney general the state
governor's senators Preet in particular
is seen as someone who's got a lot of
political ambition so yes pardon a PR
group to come in and more so than normal
well he in particular was seen as being
very sensitive to the press coverage yes
okay here is this isn't 2012 we're
talking again about Mark Matt mark Toma
who is now
as the criminal complaint in this case
alleges by cultivating and corrupting a
doctor with access to secret drug data
former portfolio manager Mathew martoma
and his hedge fund benefited from what
might be the most lucrative inside tip
of all time in any case this is
certainly the most lucrative insider
trading scheme ever charged allegedly
resulting in an illegal windfall to the
hedge fund of more than a quarter of a
billion dollars and that's billion with
a B did dr. Gillman I don't know if you
used the word flip on this he did he'd
become a he did he became the star
witness in the government's case against
Martin how big a deal was this for Preet
Bharara this was a very significant case
I mean as he just mentioned it was some
two hundred and seventy five million
dollar profit so that made it just
monetarily I think the biggest insider
trading case ever and how did they
initially figure out that this was an
insider trading case what I know you've
got again the Securities and Exchange
Commission is that an independent group
in Washington independent of the
president well it's a regulatory agency
and the chair and you know there are
commissioners who oversee the SEC and
there's a chair who's normally appointed
by the president so often the SEC is
ostensibly independent however it relies
on Congress for its funding and its
budget and it will reflect the political
views of the Chairman so in the recent
chairman well the the outgoing chairman
is Mary Jo white who used to be the US
attorney in the Southern District of New
York way back yes she had preached jobs
she was at devil boys and plimpton she
was in private practice for a long time
I have to say that a lot of the activity
that you know I cover in this book this
sort of swirling rampant insider trading
a lot of it took place in the years
leading up to the financial crisis when
the SEC was managed for at least some of
that time by by people who didn't really
believe in regular
you know and there was a sense that the
market could regulate itself there was a
very deregulatory environment is a lot
of his during the George Bush era and at
the end of it we we ended up with this
huge mortgage fraud crisis and this
insider trading crisis the commissioners
are appointed by the president approved
by the Senate so they're sitting there
and then down the street is the FBI yes
so they're independent and they're very
different
the SEC is supposed to be you know there
are all sorts of different divisions but
there's the vaunted enforcement division
inside the SEC and they're there to
enforce securities laws and they are
often doing the very painstaking
difficult work of looking at suspicious
trades so if something happens in the
market for example you know one day
there's an announcement that I don't
know AOL and Time Warner are merging
okay this is an ancient merger but okay
they're merging well you look at the
stock chart and it looks like oh wow
Time Warner shares were up $20 yesterday
before the news came out that's really
you know it looks like somebody knew
something so that might get flagged to
the SEC someone that you know there's a
there's another agency that might send a
piece of paper to the SEC that says you
guys should look into this this is kind
of just somebody obviously knew and load
it up on the shares of Time Warner right
before this news came out okay so then
they start to send out subpoenas you
know they they will get trading records
phone records and they are doing this
really painstaking work of analyzing all
these documents and trying to figure out
if something happened that shouldn't
have happened and it can take months I
mean the Mar Thoma case took years to
kind of build put together for we leave
Matt Mar Thoma though there's a story in
the book about Harvard yes it's Stanford
and law school and clerkships and all
what is it what's the story
I mean we're beating up on him but there
are lots of other people in there but it
this story might be useful well there
was so I'll back into the story by
saying during Matt martoma
trial we all came in there to the
courthouse lower Manhattan was freezing
and one morning we show up there and his
defense lawyers are standing or at the
New York Times in their hand they're
quite and rage
and on the cover I think of the business
section there was this headline to the
effect of Mathew martoma falsified
transcripts and was expelled from
Harvard Law School that's on the front
of the New York Times in the middle of
this guy's criminal trial and his
lawyers were very concerned that members
of the jury who were supposed to kind of
be impartial and neutral might see this
so the the story behind the story is
that you know Martin was this very
ambitious student he went to Duke he he
then gained admission to Harvard Law
School incredible accomplishment after I
think it was after his first year he
starts struggling a little bit you know
when he's surrounded by these very
ambitious students and everyone's
getting these incredible clerkships for
the summer and preparing for their
careers and you know they're all
competing for these coveted summer jobs
and Mar Thoma did not feel that his
grades were quite strong enough to get
him one of these clerkship positions
that he really wanted he got some B's is
what you're saying he may mean a couple
B's in there mixed in with the a you
know I mean it was a transcript that
many parents would have been happy with
there wasn't sort of perfect so he is
alleged by Harvard to have doctored his
transcripts and then applied for these
clerkships
and someone noticed something was a
little off school at Harvard at Harvard
and Harvard is obviously like probably
all schools they're very sensitive to
scandals like this so they they
conducted an investigation and they they
concluded that Mar Thoma had falsified
the transcripts then lied about it to
try and cover it up they were very
unhappy they voted to expel him and he
fought very hard and trying to convince
them not to and you know tried to tell
them that he had you know he had tried
to solve the fix the problem he'd
apologize all this stuff they just
didn't they didn't accept it
so he's pushed out he continued to fight
for you know to fight to be to be
reinstituted into the program and they
didn't go for him I want to go we all
have a whole lot of time left but I want
to go to a page page 293 in your book
and
you'll see what the purpose of this it's
a whole page about Cohen's ex-wife
Patricia and that relationship but it
gets down to meanwhile the prosecutors
and regulators involved in the billing
the case against Cohen at s AC have
moved on to more lucrative careers
purpose of asking of this is what should
we think about this we I'll read Lorin
Reisner they had a barreras Criminal
Division who helped negotiate sa C's 1.8
billion dollar fine became a partner
Paul Weiss in the same offer him that
supplied Cohen's legal defense team oh
and the list goes on well I know Antonio
apse the prosecutor who tried the
Steinberg case which is one of those
that you write about left the government
for a partnership at Milbank Tweed
Hadley in Macomb McCoy another corporate
law firm where she does
white-collar defense work I could go on
really barreras deputy Richard's able
announced that he was taking a job as
general counsel at a hedge fund called
Elliot management there more but so a
lot of people would look at that and say
that is the revolving door and that is a
big part of the problem we have in
Washington which is that they're people
going from the public sector to the
private sector and sort of cashing in on
their time in the public sector and
they're not and then and then when
they're doing their jobs as prosecutors
or regulators they're not actually doing
their job because they're trying to set
up a future high-paying job in the
private sector and it looks let me read
some more because it just keeps going
after 25 years of the FBI BJ Kang's
former supervisor Patrick Carroll joined
goldman sachs as a vice president in its
compliance group you continue arlo
devlin-brown who led the bar toma
prosecution became a partner at
Covington & Burling a law firm these are
mostly our law firm yep the most
startling move of all however came from
Amelia Cottrell a senior enforcement
attorney at the SEC the Securities and
Exchange Commission who oversaw the
agency's Mar Thoma investigation at the
end of June June
a 2015 she shocked her colleagues by
announcing that she was going joining
Wilkie far the firm whose Cohen's
long-term longtime defense counsel Marty
clots worked should we as a public worry
about this I think it raises questions
now I need I'm feel like I need to point
out that for these people I think I
think it seems entirely normal to people
in the legal profession to do this they
they put in a few years working for the
government they're making a lot less
money than they could be making working
at yeah white-shoe law firm and then at
the end of it it's time to move on maybe
they want to make more money if it's
time to send their kids to private
school and it seems very normal to them
to just go get another job in the
private sector at for millions of
dollars potentially many of them make
millions I mean some of the people in
those videos now I know are making five
million dollars a year so well they were
I mean I know in the government salaries
is somewhere between 120 150 thousand
dollars I don't know exactly what
they're they're still respectable
salaries but I think if you're living in
New York City and you're surrounded by
all these fancy Wall Street people all
the time that doesn't seem like a lot of
money doesn't go that far so a lot of
them and and of course they have these
fancy Ivy League law education and they
could make they can make a lot more
money than that and I think also
government work is just very exhausting
- it takes a huge toll from your
experience by the way you write it's
almost impossible to prosecute corporate
criminals who operate at the highest
levels well so this is where I think
this story is actually really important
from a policy perspective because here
we are you know there are almost no well
no senior executives were charged with
crimes related to the financial crisis
no one went to jail for that of any
relevance you could say the same thing
about the insider trading stuff I mean
Raj Rajaratnam who's 100 it'd go to jail
but they really did not get a lot of
people and now we have this new era in
Washington where we have a lot of Wall
Street financiers in the Kin
president Trump's cabinet and his main
message to Wall Street so far is that
he's going to cut taxes and then he's
going to gut
a regulation so I think it's a it's an
area of concern I think people need to
think about it and I think this story is
an important reminder of why intelligent
regulation is actually really important
why it's important to prosecute fraud
and crime in the white-collar world and
you know if you don't do that you end up
with a system that is favoring the
extremely wealthy and well-connected and
leaving everyone else outside and it's
just not a fair transparent system one
last story Michael Steinberg the perp
walk the whole idea of being arrested by
the FBI how do they do this and by the
way where is he today well you told us
earlier his conviction was overturned so
he's a free man and is he trading I
actually don't know he was looking into
alternate careers last I heard he's very
wealthy so he can do a lot of different
things you know the how did the arrest
go by because that's an interesting
story
sure yeah well so so the FBI was
arresting a lot of people a lot of fancy
rich hedge fund guys during this period
and he worked for si si
he worked for si si he was working there
at the time he was arrested I guess he'd
been put on leave shortly before but and
the FBI really made a point you know
often these hedge fund defendants who
had these very high-priced smart lawyers
they would say you know they would kind
of know they were possibly gonna be
arrested and they'd say well they call
up the prosecutors and they'd say well
can can we just come in voluntarily we
don't want the FBI storming into our
Park Avenue penthouse in a you know
arresting our guy in front of his family
it's embarrassing and it's really
upsetting and the FBI was very adamant
that they did not want to treat these
hedge fund defendants any differently
from a drug dealer or a petty criminal
because those people do not have the
luxury of having their white-collar
lawyer call up and walk them in in a you
know civilized fashion so the FBI kind
of made a point of busting in the doors
of these hedge fund guys early in the
morning that usually show up at 5:00 or
6:00 a.m. and there's this sort of very
tense scene I described in the book
where Michael Steinberg knows he's been
kind of tipped off he's going to be
arrested
and he caught he returns to Manhattan
from a family vacation in Florida and he
gets dressed and at 5:00 in the morning
he's sitting in his Park Avenue
apartment with his attorney and just
waits because he knows they're coming
and sure enough right on cue
bang-bang-bang
FBI you know and they came in and arrest
him what they take him they took him to
I guess they call it central processing
it's a building in lower Manhattan and
he gets fingerprinted and arraigned and
they put handcuffs on him they did
handcuff him they put him in a car
there was a Wall Street Journal reporter
had been tipped off about the arrest and
and she stood on the street and
videotaped it with her phone and that
video got played on the internet so it
was very humiliating for him and and and
considering the fact that his conviction
was later overturned you can understand
why he would be pretty upset about this
how long have you worked for The New
Yorker since July what do you do before
that right before that I was a writer at
Bloomberg Businessweek so when you look
back at this book what what am what were
the important moments for you or people
or devices for you to be able to write
this book interesting question well
personally I found it fascinating to get
to kind of go inside an investigation
like this
I had never become so deeply enmeshed in
an FBI SEC criminal prosecution the way
I was able to reporting this book and I
just found that to be really interesting
and I saw the whole process in all its
flaws you were you there with BJ Kang
when he was taking listen to the phone
calls no but I was able to relive it all
through my reporting how those times you
get to the whole story I mean more
people let you in behind the scenes you
will have to read the book and judge for
yourself it certainly felt that way to
me but so let's go back the question
what was the you know who shined the
light the most from your standpoint or
who is the best
whose character in the book and I hate
to use that term but I mean who was the
hero for you where should the boy is the
public looks at it who should they say
that's who I trust that's an interesting
question that's a tough one
I don't know if I would boil it down to
a matter of heroes or not I think
everyone even the people you would
typically think of us maybe the heroes
like the FBI agents were flawed they did
some things wrong they certainly you
know they were a little over-aggressive
at different points you could you could
say some people's lives got completely
wrecked and kind of for nothing in the
end but you know to some extent I feel
like the the investigators working at
the SEC are kind of the unsung heroes to
some extent they do not usually get a
lot of public glory and they're doing a
lot of really difficult work of just
regulating and monitoring the securities
markets and we live in a world where
everyone has money in the stock market
we all have retirement money in the
stock market so these hedge funds though
do affect the average person investing
in the stock they absolutely do because
we're all in there our futures are tied
up in the stock market and increasingly
we have two markets we have we have the
market for the wealthy well-connected
sophisticated investors like hedge fund
traders and the one for everyone else
one personal question before we close
we're out of time are you married yes do
you have a family yes kids how old are
the kids can I ask why you're asking no
reason just want to know we I've always
asked you oh you do okay sorry do you
want to ask me again then I know how old
your kids are nine and five and no one's
ever asked me that before so that's why
yeah yeah I don't want to know anymore I
don't want to know where you live no one
has ever asked me about them but during
an interview but that's fun
all right the name of the book is black
edge on the cover is a shark repped and
money what's that from it was inspired
by a sculpture that Steve Cohen is
famous for owning a dame
Hurst sculpture of a shark suspended in
formaldehyde he paid eight million
dollars for it
subtitle inside information dirty money
and the quest to bring down the most
wanted men on Wall Street sheila Kohut
car is our guest thank you very much
thanks